[Music]
uh
councillors do you have any conflicts of
interests that need to be declared at
this point in time
no thank you and we need to move on
then to the confirmation of minister
reports
uh
is
motion is carried
uh confirmation of the report of the
meeting of the community strategy
committee helped
penn state foreign
[Music]
so the recommendations contained within
that report
will
are there any
uh
which was out here in public um
and if i may
take you back to the previous item
on this agenda which was on page number
seven
and it said it states that uh
it was a question asked by councillor
matt danella
why the council need to go to the
committee for for a for the elizabeth
street stillwater
separation and um the chief executive
the item had previously been considered
committee and residents of the affected
area had not
yet been consulted it was important to
consult with
residents
so on thursday the fifth
of february we have an upsell for times
and it's an excellent article to try
uh but let's see an ideas raised as part
of the goal district council streets
life project
will start being trialled early next
year and could include closing the
street from the town's main business
center
now i had a number of business building
owners
coming to me during the week last week
they've approached me
and i asked me what the hell is going on
no one has been consulted
no one has even been asked about
these are the business and building
owners of the affected district
because it didn't maintain it
hats off to the council for consultation
consultation is a fantastic way of
getting things done
consulting with unfinancially
effective residents and people of
certain areas to me
needs address you know it's a step two
but
yeah this we're not playing a game here
this is people's livelihood i
employ six people and i don't know
whether this is a conflict but then just
your worship but all right
um
the report be received but the affected
business and building owners are
consulted with
first regarding any claims
so just in terms of clarity the report
in terms of communication that would be
the reporter who was
sitting in the room that was recording
the discussion so
my understanding would be that any
outcomes that might come
from streets
which would include any business owners
or experienced drivers depending on what
chief executives
considering uh reasons of the thing that
the area is
not consulted and being consulted before
it goes properly
this report went public last week was
taught
but my understanding was that the
meeting was talking about the streets of
the live
streams live project as a whole um
potential potentially affected
[Music]
because that's
um
discussion
and look it's fair to say that over the
years there has been quite a lot of
discussion
around what are options for the cbd in
i
the nationalisation of the section of
town was one church work
cancer green did not think the retailers
would be too happy with media chains
being opposed in the lead up to
christmas
but this is all pertaining to something
happening
and that was all something happened in
public as a discussion
that the council had positioned itself
to
put in place and was about to
move into that space and we thought we
need to
just have it confirmed and private and
alert other
effective residents that this is our
account
way of thinking streets alive as well as
worshipers
was quite a public process in terms of
providing feedback from the community
community
and as a result of that one of the ideas
was uh
segments of the expert or the cbd
and it's in that suite of ovals and
because
festive season so it was always
something that sort of i think that
might be
so people were just suddenly taken by
surprise
about what was on the ground and then in
the trial it's just that
and depending on what feedback is then
the council has to make performance
whether it proceeds
or whether it backs off and says that's
not the flight
so that's the kind of the background to
it
it was a very public process at the
outset and certainly i was keen to
get the staff to talk to the full
council about speech right because
there's a lot going on out in the
community
yeah i guess just to further clarify in
my mind anyway
any particular area that was likely to
be affected by any change
there would be quite a lot of discussion
with affected puppies
[Music]
i guess that's that's one of the
challenges of living in a democracy
that's
seem to be reasonably transparent
but councillor mcfarland
just listening intently to the
conversation here
my understanding is that the community
group that's been
established to assist with the
implication of the uh
the twelve volunteers from the community
may include people that are involved in
the business and learning
industry so i don't think there's any um
any issue around the consultation
process
but as stated at the meeting
it's only the report to be recorded and
to actually uh
inform the full council on uh what
approaches have been made and where
we're heading and i agree with the fact
that obviously that
we can't curtail was reported by
media at hanging out at a public meeting
and the items they put in there so
whether that's caused an issue here
maybe we need to readdress that um
further on in the process with this the
streets alive project
i don't think there's uh any major issue
here on
standardly corrected i believe there
that took place there so uh and i do
believe that it's still
a trial situation and um obviously still
open to some consultation consultation
process
so the recommendation of the
so um suggesting a promotion
well my question was the members of
their recommendation that report
received and
business owners and building and
business owners on the affected street
in certain benefit is that going to be
that straight
are um consulted with before any queens
are actually put in place because
uh they're the ones that make vlogging
serious so
here i don't disagree with that
[Music]
um
absolutely enough of what the plan looks
so we have a motion is there any other
council that's going to make any comment
thank you bishop um
at the meeting um i also
think that it would have been better if
people were foreign
i think the amendment needs to be
broader and it needs to
encompass any business owner or
street that may be affected needs to be
engaged with
because there won't be just your extract
of the other streets
so my my thoughts
but i think any effective party is
um
i know that um when we've been at the
community engagement sessions
um what came out again and there were
different groups that were consulted
with and business phones being
and i think the only business owners who
turned up that night were
councillor grant mr mcphail from the
theater
and the lady who was an owner of new
world
and so and there
but the intention was always as i
understand it from
mr stanford that once these ideas are
put in place there will definitely be
engagement with the people
so i think it's a given that that's what
the intention is
but i understand council davis's
[Music]
recommendation
um
it's really important to engage
affected areas how do you know what an
effective area is if you if you're in a
consultation period
if you're consulting with an affected
area it means you've already made a
decision
[Music]
i think probably we're a little bit of
spandex in terms of terminology
i think the important thing for streets
alive as a project to succeed
is active participation and engagement
with everybody that's potentially
affected
with any idea that might come along and
potentially be trial irrespective of
whether it's
in a next street or canning street or
wherever
it might be in the community so it's
just that
making sure that we're engaging and i
think personally i like the
chair of engaging rather than consulting
engaging means a much more active
process than a consultant which is
really
just getting some feedback from people
it's really only what was discussed
and the liberator liberated on
at that particular meeting as opposed to
the whole streets of life
discussions
[Music]
so
areas and other streets
so um if so if this
particular motion was to fail then
we'd move on to the second although
that's being noted and if that's the
case
uh
so everybody understands
[Music]
along the lines that properties
in within the concerns
of proposed trials arising out of the
strength of life programming being the
subject of
um
[Music]
procedures
[Music]
from
there any other notices of uh items
there's not some kind of mood that
they've been considered as urgent items
[Music]
[Music]
yes thank you i would just like to
point out the good work that sports
southpaw does
within the board district as you will
see by the
supporting information from the past
year the amount of
different activities and supporting or
community-based events that's for
example
to
the past
okay so the item is open um is there any
questions
with regard to uh school sales annual
report like i endorse the comments that
um
mr sober has made i think that sports
salesmen are
quite integral to the sporting and
recreational activities
in this part of the promise and
certainly a valued member
of the schooling sector here
i too thank them
[Music]
and i see in there there was a comment
about someone who was keen to have
another event in the middle of winter
do you think there'll be any uptake to
move that forward
these events are driven by enthusiastic
people
so if there's enough enthusiastic people
and i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
south
okay does anybody have any questions or
queries
uh just wondering why district council
is not mentioned
just curious really
uh yeah through the worship the
largely the leader of expectations has
been
driven by southward
[Music]
and we just said look we're still trying
to form a
fixed view of what specific services
on the ground here in the district as
opposed to generic stuff that
to be fair south we always thought they
needed a
tourism that has changed
dramatically and so has actually feared
the focus of
the great south around business
resilience
particularly in the terrorism event
[Music]
a lot conversion by email with the chief
financial officer of
great south and said that we will be
in touch in fact and has actually
still meetings to convince discussions
about
what can be provided for us
so i'm in a recently regular
conversation with um
just about an actually
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
animal control
um
so the recommendation is
is
[Music]
contractors connected with the
the seed operator here in this document
will be going to go in training
because of
at the same time
had lunch with the cable city council to
provide us with some training for
all of these new staff
[Music]
all um thank you
okay thank you um
[Music]
apprentice for um southbound this year
uh where is a
deliberation of southern councils we
have had one
descending voice in terms of southern
district but they
have come back to the table so we're
hopeful to see them back in the fall
on christmas so we uh plan to go forward
with
the new coordinator in the new year
and that will progress the five-year
plan that uh
dr any admission
[Music]
we have some areas where we do have a
lot of community input
and it's very relevant that we
[Music]
i worship i'm not sure if i've got a
conflict but i do have an interest in
people 2015 there's two
forest hills foundation i think that
interest
i'd like to it's um it's a really good
report
annie and i have to say the work that
she's done on predator
in 2015 has been very impressive
um and i'm just wondering is there any
opportunity perhaps to apply for some
funding to the
jobs for nature for donald trump
they there is quite a lot of funding
here if we
create some jobs through tracking or
feature control
that could be um
[Music]
um
it could be really good
[Music]
things that have to be hunted down
how far do we go with some of this stuff
you know i like to just try to defend my
frustrations
um just through my monitoring on foreign
thank you very much
control farmers between millions and
millions of dollars controlling possums
within five years back
and they're back in full swing and
really it's up to farmers and officially
to control them now with
help from the regional council and i
noticed we're the four cousins are there
our district doesn't have many um
funding of help from the regional
council they seem to keep close to
vocabulary
and their own district so um just what
you've got left is the poor cousin again
paying our ten thousand
and we need to get our share of um
action on this
but i mean i noticed also that their
first project is
the coastline in our own and so
basically i think we're going to leave
getting some of the larger areas of
landscapes
controlled and then working into the
smaller areas so
we're definitely uh on the radar for the
portion of the hills and that's really
where i'm pushing
i guess we've just got to keep pushing
our environment
there
thank you for the opportunity i
appreciate it
from
in part of the report you require
resourcing and funding to support the
relevant tools
technology and the community engagement
i presume that's for
the cute day or is it are you asking for
funds
through to the gdc or asking the fund
through
[Music]
so have you been acquired there you go
acquired the external funding to give
out the equipment
it didn't matter through the chair at
this stage we haven't applied for the
funds that area but
[Music]
thank you then i'm just
wondering how long we've been paid into
this
how would we be paying into this game at
what point
will we come up on the radar
uh through the chair with the
funding allocation on the asset
management plan that will go through the
ltp was for five years
so just indulge me so is it essential
to actually put money into this or can
we withhold it until we get
to our district uh through the chair
it's like here that we are part of the
process
because there is a lot of technology
advances in terms of
it's not just old gym traps like blood
source
it's becoming a lot more um
i guess there's like a number of um
[Music]
the comments that he has made around
understanding and accessing
technology is pretty cool and there has
been a lot of
really good volunteer work done parts of
the areas that
we're going to be focusing on so
[Music]
because i would like to make sure that
we're actually getting ready for money
out of this
cs to start dakota
so if i can move that place
i just have a free worship uh question
for edward
um fuel cats are a huge issue
in new zealand but they kill about 1.5
billion
wildlife birds per year per annum
if we got any thoughts about creating
some
policies or violence around
cats and the damage that they do
through the chair not to my knowledge at
this point in time however i do concur
that they do cause damage to the
natural biodiversity um
um
[Music]
um
so i think it was really
um
is
the reason being
so we haven't done that at this point in
time
so the um the request would be
that uh with the council for parents
that we nominated
two councillors to hear those
and then we can talk back to the council
[Music]
is
at that point
uh is there any discussion it's not a
promotional those are over the place
um
[Music]
we've got current leaders 55 percent and
they
the rest of them are stretched out at 45
percent
is that increasing because almost 50
percent of our demands are overdue
so if i was running a business that
would be a very bad sign
through your russia this is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you um
okay
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
just one one question is the number of
rating units in the district hasn't
changed from one unit
i find that hard to believe
that's not page um 117
um just a disclosure
6019 rating units um both years
i think there'll be a change
could well be right again
that any operations
topographical areas and layout changes
through the
two percentages
as a
is
is our interest swaps for the year cost
us 555
the council money to do that rather than
being
floating but that's just right if you've
got any policies
[Music]
okay other questions or comments
[Music]
um
are there any questions regarding
this particular set of minutes they're
not the promotional
collaboration
his stewardship you can expect this to
be a regular item
on the agenda
free water reform is upon us and
the council has
[Music]
about opportunities for collaboration
with
space
so the reports before you were
considered recently by the
strengths and weaknesses of each of the
participating councils
assets staff have welding and what
issues they have performing
that will be quite interesting myself
just to see
how we will stand up and
since i wrote that report of course
government has announced
its ministerial lineup for the next
three years
champion of the improvement of drinking
water in
beyond so i think we can expect
fair degree of momentum accident
on achieving some terrible syria
this of course will also help inform
the council when it's confronted with
the decision
next year
[Music]
concedes of funding that would get a
further connection
to the fray of uh more detailed
discussions around reforms
manager of the southern district council
so billy
of that process
[Music]
um
is
so the first set of minutes to be
considered
as a version item
if there's any questions i want to
answer if any councilman um
rumors uh for any questions
is
brings us
uh
um
[Music]
um